I told you not to put metal in the side  so don't you do that for it's such a big  deal just get another one come I gave me  comment time why don't you just marry  car might get a little gold microwave  and put it on a chain around your neck  you want to be more like carmine why  don't you build something like he does  instead of all your empty deals it's  just like your [ __ ] science oven you  know I read that it takes all of the  nutrition out of our food it's empty  just like your deals empty empty  [ __ ]  it's not [ __ ] I read it in an  article look I Paul bird or bring  something into this house that's gonna  take all the nutrition out of our food  and then light our house on fire thank  God for me